夏は外で遊ぶ機会が増えると思うんですけども
みなさまフリスビーで遊ぶでしょうか？
こう投げるとすごい飛んでいくんですよ
いくぜ！
というわけで、フリスビー結構夏の間みんな遊ぶと思うんですけども
そんな速度で遊んでていいのか？
もう人間の力じゃ出せないぐらいの速度でフリスビーを投げたいと思ったので
今回は外なんですけども
最近非常に使用頻度が高い、こちらの高速ドリルを使って、今回はフリスビーの速度を限界まで高めて、
あと、ドラゴンボールである、「気円斬」。
ドラゴンボールでよく見る、あのクリリンが使う気円斬をね
このフリスビーと高速ドリルを使って再現してみようと思います。
外だと電源が無いので、今回こちらのポータブルバッテリーを用意しました。
これ押すと、電源が入って
ここに差し込めばもう使えます。
ギュイーーン！
今回この速度を使って、
(ギュイーーン！)
接着剤か何か
怖いほんと一回切るね
接着剤か何かでこうフリスビーをくっつけて、
回転させて、ウッ！って投げたら、
多分気円斬で飛んでくんじゃねぇかと
では行こう！
フリスビーを何個か準備しました。
これをちょっと接着剤でまずくっつけていきます。
OK!
中心をしっかりとります。
これでしばらく放置します。
あぁこれ怖い。
ウォウ！
きたきたきたきた
はい、というわけで完成しました。
気円斬の完成ですｗ
回転してる時におもいっきりブンッ！って振ったら、
飛んでいきます。
(カメラマン)なるほど。
ではやってみよう！
あああ！
(カメラマン)おっ！おっ！
あああああああ！
ああああ！
むずいよ！
まってまってまって
あぁーダメだダメだ
おぉっ、おいおいきたきたきた！
やろやろやろ！
もうなんか良きタイミングで投げますわ。
こい！
ああああああ！
気円斬見たいだろ？
(カメラマン)見たい。
(カメラマン)でも今ちょっと気円斬ぽかったもん。
気円斬ぽかった？音は気円斬だった
これ行けるんじゃないすか？
現代のクリリンはこんな感じでございます。
今もう投げるよ！
痛っ！！！
何が起きた今？
(カメラマン)フリスビーがそこにとどまってたｗ
何投目だ?
では行きます。
オラァ！！！
ﾎﾟﾄｯ
しんどくね？これ
穴開けたいね。やっぱり
ちょっとこれしんどいわ
(カメラマン)いや無理だよｗ
(カメラマン)え？え？
(カメラマン)入った？
おっしゃあ！
わああああ！きたきたきた！！！
おい、おい！
(カメラマン)入った！きた！
見たかｗｗｗ
え、きたでしょこれ！
はい、というわけで、高速ドリルで無理やり穴を開けたので、
え？めっちゃ綺麗じゃん
ちょっと作戦変更です。
接着剤があんまり付かなかったので、
偶然穴が空いたので
この穴を高速ドリルに付けて、
このまま回転させて勢いでブン投げてみようと思います。
行きます。
ヤバイヤバイヤバイ！
うわ！うわ！うわ！うわ！うわ！
見た？
(カメラマン)やべぇｗヤバイヤバイヤバイ
見た見た見た？
気円斬！
いやいやいやｗ長いよｗ
長い！長い！長い！長い！
オラァ！
うわ！
やばいやばいｗ
気円斬終了のお知らせｗ
(カメラマン)気円斬作りの匠だよｗ
すぐ作れるぞー！ｗ
おぉっ！！！
【この字幕は視聴者によって作られました】